[Music]
I'm the one
oh
okay folks uh look we decided to be the
first podcast to do the responsible
thing
and and mask up because we're concerned
about your study came up from a city
called
um am I pronouncing this correctly Adam
ravensburg
Germany which is the home of uh uh this
gentleman sweetheart of a guy uh Klaus
Schwab who believes uh now there's
possibilities of you getting covered
through watching podcasts so what we
decided to be fully responsible and wear
this mask again will break it on your
eyes
it's been two years I forgot how to use
it can you show us the articles that
came out with different companies here's
Lionsgate reinstates mask mandate in
charts of Santa Monica office following
covet outbreak and what's the other one
that's doing it as well Atlanta College
brings back covet mask mandates as
Government doctors in Seattle call for
face coverings to be compulsory for
health care workers amid rise of new
covet variant ba to that 0.86 so folks
we're being responsible but having said
that for the sake of Living in America
we're going to be free and take this
off yeah it's the Mandate problem
hey you remember what Arnold
Schwarzenegger said how would you free
them yeah you want to wear the mask
screw yourself
all right so listen I just told Klaus
Schwab to kiss my tush
respect it's okay listen a lot of
Stories the debate's coming up tomorrow
night the first debate Trump's not going
to be there he's saying he's not going
to be there apparently he's going to be
doing a show with Tucker Carlson ghosted
together which he's got a 46 point lead
he's got a big 20 23 point lead in Iowa
and there's a lot of people not happy
about it but but he's not shown I will
talk about that there's going to be
predictions on what we think is going to
happen with the uh debate tomorrow
mortgage rates hits record-breaking
highs in 21 years uh Adam is making
static noise as China falls into the
deflation the mood turns dark we'll talk
about there's a video I want you to
watch from China looking for a new car
under twenty thousand dollars good luck
your choice has dwindled to just one
vehicle America's fight over tipping at
restaurants comes to its biggest
Battleground yet how much do you tip CNN
Jake Tapper was forced to do something
he didn't want to do you got to see this
clip but you know what I respect them
for even saying it uh where no one's
saying it in that channel Larry Ellison
throws money behind Tim Scott and not
just three thousand three hundred
dollars he throws some real money behind
Tim Scott for 2024. Tom will cover that
Murdoch asks gop's Glenn Younkin to run
for president in 2024 Hawaii Biden shows
up folks you know a person is winning
and doing very well with the crowd when
I show you this clip of the warm welcome
President Biden got when he got to
Hawaii driving up in his car in security
yeah it's there's going to be a moment
where in this podcast you may get
emotional I think it's going to be when
I show you this clip brace for impact
Biden campaign predicts GOP candidates
will outmeg each other at the debate I
don't think that's going to happen
because there's a lot of people that
don't want Maga to be leading the way
Anheuser-Busch renues partnership with
Washington Commanders
as team's official beer sponsor Kid Rock
apparently was seen drinking Bud Light
Vinnie what what happened no way oh my
gosh yeah Americans burning through
excess savings from the pandemic will
cover that stay home dads well maybe
we'll cover that a stunning social
change a lot of people are alone today
uh we talked about the debate few things
with Trump Biden Hawaii will cover that
and then uh you know the scientists
comment about what was the list vessels
listless vessels
and then maybe we'll give a quick shout
out to Rachel Maddow and there's some
stuff that's going on with Logan Paul
Jake Paul and Dylan Dennis that I think
we will eventually comment on today
having said that let's get right into
mortgage rates Tom mortgage rates soar
to their highest level in 21 years U.S
mortgage rates a 30-year fix officially
average
7.09 in the week ending August 17 up
from 6.96 to Prior week according to
Freddie Mac Rising rates have been
persistent exceeding six and a half
percent since May and have climbed
further since mid-july the last instance
of rates over seven percent was in
November of the preceding year and the
current average rate is the highest
since April of 2002. we're talking pre
big short we're talking pre Michael
burry saying the real estate market is
going to collapse this is right after 9
11 is what we're talking about the
surgeon mortgage rates is affecting home
affordability and sales with a
combination of low inventory and higher
costs leading to a 20 20 or 20 drop in
home sales compared to the previous year
despite the strong economic growth
challenges arise from high cost and
inflation concerns Tom
this is huge what's huge about it is
that this is a national average this
isn't like a regional Spike you know
we've looked up here and we've had Rob
go on there and you know pull pull the
averages on the Google search and you
can see eight percent in certain areas
this is a national average and the
national average has grown now 7.09
percent on a national average is bad
that really means that you probably have
some areas out there and some types of
consumers that are seeing eight and a
half eight and a quarter if they're even
choosing to get into that mortgage
because when you translate the buying
power of an eight and a half that's not
a whole lot of house and prices are
staying High because the inventory is
staying low this is what we thought was
going to happen last year is now
happening this year and remember the FED
says they may not be done raising
interest rates or maybe another quarter
point coming in the fall okay so let me
ask you a question when do you think
it's going to go back down six percent
less than six percent
I think I'm looking now at um
end of first quarter next year because
that's when the FED says that they will
be considering remember they have to see
line of sight and see that two percent
inflation and then the FED is talking
about like maybe next year early second
quarter they might give a quarter point
back but they don't want to see wage
growth too hot and they do not want to
see
um inventory excuse me inflation above
two percent so it's um
it's we're probably probably here for
the next nine months and the fed's not
helping because they're saying well you
know in the uh in the late Autumn which
is right in the middle of the upcoming
six month uh window I'm talking about
here oh we may throw another quarter
point at it we're still not happy that
inflation's down this is bad and now we
have National averages here and as you
pointed out
April 2002 folks that was a recession
ahead six years ahead Tom let me have a
financial crash October 28th of next
year where will rates be
October 28 of 2024 where do you predict
rates will be October 28 2024 a week
before election where will rates be I
think it'll be back down to like a sixth
national average maybe a five seven five
five seven five October 28 of next year
so you still think it's going to be
pretty high but it's going to be less
than six
yeah and less than the 709 that's here
and less than six I think the incumbent
Biden Administration will do everything
they freaking can they're they're
manipulating the job stats we've talked
about this at length so I think that
they're going to do everything they can
to encourage the FED to to drop it a
little bit Yeah I fully agree I believe
that the uh current Administration will
do everything they can to artificially
inseminate the economy
um
especially during an election year
obviously they want everything in their
favor Biden doesn't have a ton to run on
his approval ratings are in the low 40s
uh dropping uh we've got two leading
candidates Trump and Biden both in the
low 40s National averages so if you have
the power of the purse and you have
Jerome Powell on your side and you've
got Janet Yellen on your side and you've
got you know maybe even like the big
banks on your side what have you you can
do everything you can to try to
artificially uh make the economy look
better make the stock market look better
make mortgage rates look uh as good as
they can make gas prices look lower make
everything that's going on in the
economy look as good as possible so you
are um
with a nice fake economy like the way
we've been doing for the last 20 years
and then and then just to keep in mind
with the mortgages if we kind of zoom
out just for everyone's perspective
because a lot of our listeners you know
especially if you're in your 20s and 30s
you don't remember uh prior to 2000 2002
when this is the last last time that
rates were this High seven percent if
you go back to when you know literally
our parents let's say or Tom maybe you
bought your what year did you buy your
first house first year
92. okay so 92 so just to give you guys
some context out there in the 80s under
Reagan's presidency following your good
friend Jimmy Carter the reason that
you're in this country shout out to
Jimmy I think he's about to be 100 by
the way I want to say that the average
rate was somewhere in the 12 to 18 rage
I think it maxed out at 18 and a half
percent think about that that is a
credit card that you're putting a house
on you're putting a mortgage on that's
insane if you're paying 18 on your
credit card I'd be raising like the Red
Alert red flag do not be paying that
much money that's how much money people
were paying for houses
no hell no that's unsustainable nobody's
gonna pay that amount of money for a
house at least I wouldn't but then as
Tom pointedly pointed out 1990s it I
think it uh at the at the heels of the
uh Bush Administration when when Clinton
got elected in 92 it go it went down to
single digits nine ten percent then we
saw it after
um 2000 you said hit seven percent I
think you said April of 2002 that's
right after 9 11 everything that
happened with that then we saw what
happened with the Obama Administration
and everything artificially
um
started heading over to say zerp zero
zero interest policy yeah exactly so
rates were what you know two three four
five percent zero and so what are you
doing in those cases I'm just giving I'm
giving some context that if you think
seven percent is high
do your research it's actually somewhat
normal over the last four years okay
good point so is your point that we
should keep it at seven point and stay
here
uh do I think we should keep as someone
that's looking to purchase the first
home hell no but I I would understand if
rates kind of stayed in the five to
eight percent range over the next decade
what do you think we should stay here I
actually think we should stay here for a
while uh I don't know if you guys are
following what's going on with China
with the development that you have going
on in China with their biggest uh uh uh
Evergreen ever not not even ever Grand
there's a company that's even bigger
than that I think it's called Country
Garden or something like that if you can
pull up Country Garden some weird name
these guys had a 441 billion won Revenue
last year in 2022 they just missed their
debt payment they literally just you
know how much their debt payment was 20
million won they missed the debt payment
how do you miss the debt this is kind of
like by the way it's a 441 billion yuan
company a year
just missed a 20 million dollar debt
payment that's like you're making just
to kind of put things in context Tom can
you do the math on that it's like you're
doing it yeah yeah if you want to do
that real quick do that if I'm doing 441
billion dollars that's nine zeros right
you miss a 20 million dollar debt
payment am I doing that correctly Adam
so that's like doing what take this take
this take this take this out now that's
like you're making 441 000 a year and
you missed a twenty dollar payment yeah
it's nothing that's what they just
missed it's supposed to be nothing wow
they missed it because they accelerated
so you know you know in China they have
a city in China uh uh the the Paris of
China have you followed the story The
Paris of China uh can you pull this up
there's a city in China uh uh uh that is
twanburg I think Tia duching this is a
city Tia duching they've built every
single thing the same way it is in Paris
in Tia ducheng that city right there is
chandelise identical the Eiffel Tower
same size identical can you go pull up
some uh type in Tian du Chang copy paste
that and go to uh go to uh Google type
that in the right next to put Paris by
the way just write that shout out to
your friendship the accents you just
go to images here it's called uh you
know having a friend that sat in front
of you that was French for a couple
semesters yeah sounds like a nice person
so so look at that identical same exact
thing in China so what are these guys
doing they're spending so much money do
you know how many vacant homes they have
in China right now do you know how many
vacant homes have in China right now you
know the number Millions 55 to 90
million estimated vacant homes and their
unemployment right now for ages 15 to 24
years old 15 to 24 years old ages 15 to
24 it's around 140 million people right
there it's 21 22 percent right on
unemployment correct they have so much
problems going on in China why because
the the knob you control as a country if
you cool and heat it up and not allow
capitalism to do it you're eventually
becoming God you're acting like God like
don't worry about it we are the gods of
economy we are Jerome Powell we are you
know fed we are the US government we are
the Congress we can do whatever we want
to fix the economy and then all of a
sudden you fabricated so much so much
success that China yet last year lost 10
800 millionaires that left the Exodus of
millionaires in China they're estimated
to lose 13 500 millionaires this year
and guess what last year in 2022 400
people in the world
fell off the billionaire list guess how
many was from China out of the 400 228.
wow let me say this one more time out of
the 400 228 fell off the billionaire
list and they're out of China so bring
this back to U.S I think we need to stay
at a seven point mark for a minute and
Realtors and loan officers I would be
saying this the message he gave which
was important let's go back to where we
were at in the 80s and 90s and this may
be the new Norm this may be the new Norm
and I would talk to my clients and I
would if I'm a loan officer right now
real time I'm going to say this listen
get this thing at seven percent today
here's why say the rates drop to five
and a half percent next year we'll refi
yeah but get it at least at seven
percent to get you and because you're
gonna get out of good prayer good price
because the problem is what if it stays
at seven percent what if it goes to
eight percent what if it goes to nine
percent lock it in at seven when it goes
lower we will refi that would be the
approach I would be taking because if
America plays with fire on wanting to be
the god of economy all of a sudden we're
going to wake up on there and saying
what the hell are we going to do with
all of this debt that we got going on
anyways my transition today's sponsor is
American Hartford gold uh you guys
already know that I I'm big on different
kinds of investment I own stock
commercial real estate residential bonds
mutual funds ETFs uh you know PE money
into different kind of you know Venture
Capital we have a lot of different
things that we do but I'm also a big
believer of gold uh during times like
this when you're seeing us print money
more and more and more they're talking
about printing another 2.6 trillion
dollars I have physical gold myself in
place I've been a guy that was in life
that's been in life insurance for 23
years I'm about the what if something
happens you have to have a lot of life
insurance what if something happens to
the economy this is when you want to go
out there and partner with American
Hartford gold uh and purchase some gold
for yourself if it's suitable give these
guys a call we chose to team up with
them we like how they work we like how
they take care of the clients you know
the rating is solid so if you've never
taken advantage of this couple things
you need to know American Heart for gold
will ship physical gold or silver
directly to you if you have retirement
funds that'll also help you with that if
it's a 401k rollover or rollover they'll
show you how to protect your savings and
retirement accounts by diversifying your
portfolio with it and they have the
finest product amazing customer service
and a buyback commitment they have
earned five star ratings from thousands
of reviews and a plus from Better
Business Bureau tell them I sent you
they'll give you up to five thousand
dollars of free silver on your first
order call
866-939-6984 again
866-939-6984 or text award pbd to 65532
again text award pbd
265-532 the link will also be in the
description okay so that that's that's
the mess that's going on in America I
wanted to kind of revisit some of the
Chinese stuff because because I think
what you're saying is
uh very important because why is China
important you know one of the biggest
lessons I've learned many of the lessons
I've learned since value table one of
the biggest lessons is the threat of
China you know what's the China by 2030
China by 2025 20 25 20 35 every year
they kind of keep pushing it back a lot
of those predictions were pre-coveted
though but since covid uh some of the
um information that they've been so uh
secretive about and they've been playing
close to the vest have sort of come to
light why because a lot of people have
been examining China and if you look at
the Wall Street Journal they've actually
done a great job we definitely Advocate
you reading the journal but here's some
of the headlines of the Wall Street
Journal in the last week number one
you talked about
um the unemployment rate of uh China's
youth right 21 so the Wall Street
Journal article says China's young
restless and jobless youth unemployment
doubled since covet 21 by the way the
government is now telling college
graduates college graduates to settle
for low-paying blue-collar jobs they're
they're quote it's okay to lie flat and
that you should work hard jobs why
because you should learn to eat
bitterness this is some of the
um vernacular that's coming out of China
interesting the second article was has
China is China past its peak all right
cool good to know uh after everything
that's going on channel that'd be
interesting to do and then you talked
about this uh sort of the billionaires
you said 222 billionaires 28 out of the
400 228 ridiculous we remember in 2020
when Jack ma went missing and why did I
was Jack ma in the headlines because
he's probably the most famous person uh
Tech billionaire out of China Alibaba
but there's so many
multi-multi-millionaires billionaires
whose names we don't know who who knows
what's happened to these guys we've seen
a tech Crackdown in China but here's the
the third article that I that I read
um Wall Street Journal China will hunt
you down so whether you're Jack ma
whether you're billionaires whether
you're uh the uyghurs that we've learned
about in uh work camps
um or whether you're you know living in
Hong Kong and you're living in fear and
you know what we know about China is
they will suppress any dissenting voice
that dares to question the CCP but
here's what's interesting about China
because for years I've we've talked
about the threat of China you know the
red communism CCP
um what was the the Admiral that we used
to have on
the gentleman who used to have a show
Spalding General Spalding I learned a
lot from him he was great
um here's what we've seen since China
all right the GDP has dropped they're
they're um
foreign investments have dropped
significantly I want to say it's 14
percent since covid uh they call it the
decoupling of China aging population we
can talk about that for a second uh
tourism is as plummeted Who the hell's
going to China these days nobody okay
foreign investments we talked about
evergrant and the other uh real estate
firm what was it called that you just
mentioned uh country uh something so you
know they have a name for these cities
they're called ghost cities yes they've
basically built up these cities with the
expectation that millions and millions
of 60 to 90 million uh residences have
been are vacant right now and nobody's
moving there so these ghost cities are
literally empty talk about listless
vessels nothing going on there but we
all know that in China there's no
freedom of speech there's no internet
there's no social media you can't
question the CCP but let's take a step
back and talk about
um GDP so we all know that um United
States is the number one country in the
world GDP so we're about what 25
trillion dollars I want to say China uh
distance second 18 trillion when it
comes to GDP right there you go so 17 18
trillion there it is and then it's not
even close when you go from three to ten
three to twelve
when you go 25 us you go 18 China and
then you have very far down below that
you got Japan Germany India UK and
France all in that three to four
trillion dollar range then you've got
like what I call the twos you got Russia
you got Australia you've got Italy
Canada Brazil Australia they're all
basically below two but here's what's
interesting China you know as as well as
they're doing as from a GDP standpoint
number two in the world there's actually
another term that they call GDP per
capita you're familiar with this it's
like all right not how much not gross
domestic product that the country is
outputting it's how much per person take
a guess where the United States is GDP
per capita don't pull it up Rob versus
China just take a guess
per person per person like rankings in
the world so if we're number one and
China's number two GDP
total GDP where is it per capita take a
guess well you got uh what 23 trillion
divided by 335 million that would be the
US number you really about the bus held
this math right now and then you would
do 18 trillion in China divided by what
two billion 1.4 billion yeah
so what do you have tell us all right
nobody wants to guess the rankings all
right fine my head hurts all right guys
we want to play this game so number one
in the world is Pat's uh arguably
favorite country uh Monaco if that's
considered a country uh a a region uh
south of France south of Italy uh so
Monaco and Luxembourg number one in
terms of GDP per capita so let's move
that out of the way United States
holding strong at but um number seven in
the world that's money in each person's
pocket so China
um not in the top ten not in the top 20
not in the top 50 they are number 64 in
the world meaning meaning there's some
rich ass billionaires yeah and some very
very poor people in real china they've
been obviously over the last three
decades their middle class has been
rising what a point you just made yeah
by the way fantastic point that you did
the research on that to share with us I
will tell you Rob can you pull up what I
just sent you uh uh okay can you go to
the charts edit the dates go to the the
right above you it says calendar right
next to the plot right there so you
write the click on that and change the
2022 to 1980. just change that to 1980.
okay check this out yeah and then put
the space between it now you kind of
messed it up yeah there you go right
there click on that okay zoom out a
little bit zoom in zoom in a little bit
so we can see it no no no no no Rob
okay go back to the day still okay there
you go so so bring us in so the audience
can see this so this is Japan and go up
there you go perfect so this is Japan
okay the perfect comparison of China to
see what's about to happen to them is
Japan and they look at the growth Japan
had this is their Dow Jones it goes from
5 000 in 1980 all the way up to 40
000 in 1990. one of the fastest growing
economies in the world this is when
Toyota was God and their seal was Jesus
okay look what happens to these guys
when they try to fabricate what fake
economy and cheap money
quickly developing everything look how
that thing goes from forty thousand in
1990 it drops all the way down to what
four thousand six thousand and two
thousand okay 2002 and then stays there
at around what year is that right there
if you look at if there's a show take
you there okay it's okay it's a 2002 and
then you go to the next bottom that you
show it's around like 2009 whatever that
bottom is there
and since 1990 till today guess what
it's never gone back to what it was
still haven't recovered yet they're
getting close still haven't recovered in
33 years they haven't recovered what
China is going through right now is
catastrophic is what they're going
through right now they're going to try
to fake it till you make it for as long
as you can but let me tell you something
when you when you fake it till you make
your luck imagine when you're hanging
out with a crowd and they're all rich
and you're trying to act like you're
rich so you go to a restaurant hey uh
yeah let's do a bottle of you know
whatever just bring you this because
hey just bring us all the Torah From The
Underground area of Japan where only the
president yeah bring us that's like I'm
gonna go to the bathroom real quick and
then all of a sudden the bill comes out
guys the bill is 38 000 but splitted
between four of us look man it's it's 95
how much you guys let's tip this guy
this guy was a good let's tip from 10
grand 50 Grand 12 500 if you want to
give your credit card like oh
what's going on here you know those
China has been living off of fake money
for a long time and their people are
starting to realize and they're slowly
wanting to leave it's kind of like this
you know how you want to leave the party
and nobody knows yeah yeah you're just
gonna leave them make sure nobody sees
me here boom I leave that's kind of what
the people in China are trying to do
they're trying to leave China without
the government or the economy knowing to
go to a different place and try to take
their money out quietly but you can't
take your money out quietly it's called
it's called an Irish exit let me say one
more stat and I'm going to hand it over
to my God the biz dog who you know he's
going to give you some good stats the
last thing that I think we should bring
up is everything that you've highlighted
with India this past year India has now
officially surpassed China as the
world's most populated country I think
India is at 1.5 billion I want to say
China's at 1.44 in the in that range
whatever the number is depending on how
many people are missing this week
um but interesting enough because of
their aging population due to their a
lot of it the effect of the one child
policy a lot of young
female babies went missing because you
know you wanted that that male son uh
here's China's population in the next
hundred years it's expected to go from
1.4 billion this year to 1 billion by
2080 okay to below a billion 800 Million
by 2100 so in the next hundred years
there you go boom stats right there so
you know what's the one idea I'm always
saying like hey Pat more chicks you know
sounds cast by the way tune in today you
know you're not helping them you got to
make kids so until you have kids when I
want to see I want to see don't make
this personal Junior Adriana Junior
sitting next we're working on that Pat
there might be a couple baby mamas but
let's not deviate but here's the
difference the one child policy has
basically turned China into an all dude
sausage fast party yeah something yeah
man that's awesome so United States
clubs in Kentucky I used to go oh no fun
by the way do not try to come in all
dudes to a club in South Beach never
gonna happen so in the United States you
have 9 98 males to 100 females so you
walk into a party there's a couple more
chicks you're like all right cool I can
get down like this that's kind of how
clubs operate typically you want more
women than men that's you know supply
and demand it's you know hypergamy at
its finest but in China it's 105 men to
a hundred females so you walk into a
party it's like God's sausage fest up in
this piece that's what's going on in
China especially with the Aging
population old men running around the
country Tom I really appreciate your
dive into it I love listening to Stats
like that and one thing I'll add to Adam
is remember one thing about Japan Japan
the 90s was the decade of Crash and then
the Otts the oos was the decade of slow
growth back and they finished 2010 at 10
000 where you saw that there so they
sort of finished where they started in
1980 and they've kind of grown past that
one of the ways that they've grown in
Japan they have a currency that's tied
to international monetary system the
then is actually actively a part of
international monetary trade currency
trade
China has never ever ever pegged its
currency to the international
monetary trade they've never pegged it
they've artificially adjusted the value
inside turning the knob which is the
same problem that Stalin had and if you
want to go back and look at this in
history with his five-year plans that he
started 1920 Five-Year Plan we didn't
make it well we're gonna make another
Five-Year Plan oh we didn't make that
another Five-Year Plan and the human
toll was terrible so when you sit inside
yourself the way China is now and the
way Stalin did what happens is you don't
get where you're going you're going to
end up somewhere else and that's exactly
what's happened here and at least Japan
learned after 20 years of strife decaded
crash decade of flat they're now coming
back but they're coming back on rational
economic policy and a currency that is
tied to all the rest of the world
currencies where you go up and down
based on the value you create by the way
the the challenge here for these guys
is you know everything is about looking
at other case studies to learn for
yourself if you can't learn from other
people's mistakes
and you repeat it you know that's your
fault it's you didn't you didn't process
what the other person's mistake was
China's now learning from Japan and we
as Americans are not learning from
history we also keep printing more money
hoping to delay the problem to the next
phase and the next phase and the next
phase this whole thing was about we
should stay at around seven percent I
think we should stay at seven percent
Plus for about a decade and see what
happens it'll discipline every by the
way I'm going to lose money if I do that
because value is going to come down but
I think we need to stay at a disciplined
number for a decade let's get stabilized
no more printing of money at the US
government unless if they can lower by
10 if you can lower our national debt by
10 you can come back and ask for more
money to be printed by us if not don't
come back asking for more money let's
just pump the break you know there's
freezes in different Industries let's
put a freeze in Congress printing more
money for about 10 years let's see what
happens what if publicly we announced
you can no longer print money unless if
a natural disaster happen you can't say
more entitlement more this more that
let's go for 10 years and see what that
looks like but knowing the the the way
our uh government is set up that is very
highly unlikely Adam I'm going to move
on okay so the next story here I want to
go to looking for new car under 20 000.
good luck your choice has dwindled to
just one vehicle and here's what that
vehicle is
uh uh the availability of affordable new
cars in the US is dramatically
diminished with only Mitsubishi Mirage
when you pull up the Mitsubishi Mirage
so we know what it looks like fully
loaded right Mitsubishi Mirage remaining
under 20 000 this shift
comes as the Mirage average sale price
is under as around 19205 contrasted
against the current average new vehicle
price of over forty eight thousand
dollars significantly higher under
pre-pandemic levels the mirage's
affordability attracts certain buyers
Karen shape what a name that makes sense
Karen's by mirages who opted for a
mirage noted that while she could have
afforded a more expensive car her
preference for a small vehicle drove her
choice the Mitsubishi mirage's future is
uncertain it might be phased out soon
leaving buyers with even fewer
affordable new options while there are
other low-cost cars like Kia Rio or
Nissan Versa the decline of sub 20 000
Auto Vehicles may lead customers to
consider certified pre-owned cars as a
viable second option is what they got
going on Tom what are your thoughts here
with the Mirage is this something we
should be looking into as a valuetaining
car
for oh my gosh it's this little car it
looks like a delivery car like you could
wrap it with a logo for doordash or
something and it just is a little
delivery car it's cute you know pulls up
to your house guy jumps out looks like
my car dude and I I think what it just
shows is what inflation has done to the
price of cars you know when the starting
point is that thing for twenty thousand
dollars and I'd love to see the uh crash
rating on that thing
um I think you you've it just underlines
again what inflation has done to
vehicles that the starting price at
twenty thousand will only get you that
now that's a little car I'm sure it's
reliable and it should be really great
if you wrapped it doordash wrap 100
start delivering and stuff doesn't take
up much space in the street but I think
it just underlines just that the the
cover charge to get a car now is twenty
thousand dollars by the way it continues
with another story about Wall Street
Journal car prices might be
unsustainable for buyers might be uh uh
well this is what Wall Street General
stomach car parts have surge in the past
five years leaving only one model which
is the Mirage 42 weeks uh the average
American now requires 42 weeks of income
to pay off a new car up from 33
pre-pandemic numbers used car prices
have risen by over 30 average and at
twenty seven thousand dollars compared
to pre-pandemic levels new car loans
demand a monthly payment exceeding 750
but in interest rates holy moly of 9.5
percent while used car loan rates are
around ready 13.7 percent uh didn't beat
my rate that I got in the Army at fmac
33 percent can Thirty I have the
contract till today Clarksville loans
issued in the past three years have an
average terms
of nearly six years despite low
unemployment auto loan delinquencies
rates are at their highest since 2006
defaults on loans from the peak pricing
surge in the first half of last year are
akin to our surpass two or surpass those
of 2008 crisis used car dealers have
limited Options under ten thousand
dollars while cars above 35 dominate the
market think about this one real quick
before the pandemic it took you 33 weeks
to pay for a new car in the 26 weeks six
months so it's 26 weeks plus a month and
you know a little bit more than half a
year nine weeks were added to that so
pre-pandemic it was 33 weeks afterwards
it was 42. that's nine weeks that's two
more months was added to the time it
takes you to
pay for a car pbd look at what happened
in the pandemic the pandemic was 22
months in 22 months we added two full
months to the time it took to pay off a
car that's what the printing money and
that's what inflation did to the average
person trying to get a car destroying
middle class the more they print money
the more they destroy middle class and
that's their goal though right that's
been their goal the whole time is it
either you're rich or you're poor yeah
but go keep the establishment that says
we need to print money to help the
middle class all they're doing
is hurting middle class and guess what
they're doing money flows to the top I
know money flows to the top so they can
print as much money as they want but
they're helping the rich kid richer go
ahead yeah I mean look I've said this
for years it's it's even more resounding
at this point the number one thing that
is killing your wealth is your car
because it's not even just your car and
your car payment it's your insurance
it's your gas it's your tag it's your
title it's your parking tickets it's
your toll fees it's I need new brake
pads I need new tires I need new this I
knew that it's valet it's going out and
that's God forbid everything goes
according to plan throw in an accident
throw in a DUI you are screwed
especially in Florida holy so you know
you talked about the rich getting richer
and the poor getting poorer we learned a
new terminology during covet called the
k-shaped economy where the people at the
top were just getting richer and the
people at the bottom were getting poorer
so there's two ways to have more money
this is for you message for the broke
boys in the chat talking all the
listen up there's two ways
um to have more money in your life uh
you can either make more or you can
spend less uh I think I've focused on
doing both constantly working to improve
my skill sets skills pay the bills
um to make more money add more income
streams or do better at your job that's
awesome that's one thing to do or make
better Investments great but the second
way to do it is to spend less and to cut
out expenditures and what I did I'm not
saying that you guys got to do it I know
there's gonna be like how could you not
have a car well stay broke
here's what I would recommend
um cut out what I would say one of the
big three expenses from your life what
are the big three expenses of your life
number one you're yep that's you Vinnie
uh number one is your housing uh that
should cost what 33 30 of your total
gross income that's your biggest expense
that's where everyone I mean you got a
place to live maybe you get a roommate
maybe you know your wife gets to work
maybe you downsize whatever it is but
the second biggest expenses is your
transportation I cut out having a car in
my life in 2011 and I live in downtown
Miami and basically out of uber
everywhere yeah I get that pat but
everybody's broke so if you want me to
recommend what everyone should do then
just stay broke but the point is this if
you live in a big city just do the math
if you're living in country buffkinville
in Kentucky obviously you're gonna need
a car you know it's also tough to do uh
uh first of all you're able to do that
in Miami I don't know how the hell you
do when you go on dates with girls they
drive you around or you take an Uber
it's kind of weird well it's not kind of
weird because it's called Uber and then
and then you're drinking and you have
wine
but it actually works out very well I I
understand you have a game that you're
doing but you're not everybody America
is not Adam Adam is less than one
percent of America that's you the the
habits about a person that we want more
people to have families and kids and
raise good kids and families that is a
POS if we had a million atoms America is
a problem just so you know because
you're not making any kids you're not
having a it's a very different uh
America that we're talking about than
just you for you what are the cars have
to do with kids because the average
person needs to take them to school but
you don't need two you don't need two
cars or three cards so now I know a good
I know
that share one car and they figure it
out but that's a different story so then
give that point as well for people that
are married with kids because the in in
today's our listeners are not uh sauce
cast listeners Adam this is a different
listenership that we have on the show
sauce cast listeners people want to
listen to you know what it is to get
laid paid whatever you know that's the
kind of stuff that that audience wants
to listen to the average American today
is sincerely sitting there saying I'm
concerned about my kids going to a
public school I need a car to pick them
up my husband's got a different job the
reason why morale and teakin were able
to make it work is because they both
work for the same company it was very
easy to do the average husband and wife
don't work for the same company we don't
have a reality of what we've been doing
the last four or five years that is not
the reality of everybody the average
person who's listening to this or
watching this is sitting there saying
dude I I want to have kids I want to
have a family I want to raise my kids
well I need a car to drop them off here
pick them up there do all this other
stuff and the prices are going up and we
keep printing more money and the more
money we print by the way every time
they print money I get richer let me say
this one more time every single time
they print money I get richer if I told
you how much money I just made in the
last six months on my money market
account you wouldn't believe it I don't
even want to say it because people are
going to be like look at this how much
money is bragging mother every time they
print money I make money okay this
concept about printing money over and
over to helping the middle class out we
have to pump the brakes and say guys
relax with all the stuff that we're
doing we have to change some of our
habits I love the line that you said
make more spend less there's two ways
that you increase your net worth you
either make more or you spend less
perfect so let's flip that on the
government
how can the government or policies hate
Middle America
how can the government help Middle
America let's let's think about that
part right there how can the government
help Middle America okay so a perfect
example to give you here
um I don't know if we talked about this
last time did we talk about the 63 000
salary or no I don't think we've talked
about I don't think so okay so Adam
Vinnie Tom Rob all of you here I want
you to think about this answer if you
make sixty three thousand dollars a year
you love your mom your father passed
away is no longer in the picture like me
sounds like you you make sixty three
thousand dollars a year what percentage
of your money are you comfortable giving
to your mom to help her out
if you make 63 a year which is roughly
fifty two hundred bucks a month what are
you comfortable giving to your mom to
help her out
a year if you make 63 63 000 a year I'm
asking a sincerely average American you
probably don't have enough money to give
your mom anything I agree but give me a
number to save five thousand dollars ten
percent tithe for your mom Tom 500 bucks
a month is probably what it would take
to help your mom get over anything okay
so let's say 500 bucks a month which at
sixty three thousand dollars that's
about 10 that's about 10 right okay
sounds good watch this do you know if
you had eight zeros to that sixty three
thousand dollars what number you come up
with our federal expenditure do you know
out of our 63 6.3 trillion dollars a
year on federal expenditure how much we
spend on entitlement programs do you
know what the number is uh What's the
total number out of 6.3 trillion what
percentage we spend on entitlement
programs or what dollar amount out of
the 6.5
probably closer to three trillion 3.3
trillion dollars we give to entitlement
program half of it let me give you
another number on this context and since
we're on this context in 1940 okay no
not 1940 go to uh 1960 years ago
whatever 60 years ago is what 1960. in
1960 1950
um what percentage of kids born in
America you think we're born to single
mothers and what year is this go to 1950
what percentage of kids being born in
America were born to single mothers I'll
tell you 10 I would say it's half of
that probably four or five percent it's
exactly four percent okay you know what
that number is today probably like 40
it's exactly 40 wow it went from four
percent to exactly 40 here's a question
for you now obviously give or take
someone's gonna say it's not exactly 41
or 39 all I'm saying to you is the one
from four to forty percent how do we get
here
how do we get from four to forty percent
welfare Queens you actually think of do
you know we are one of the worst
countries if not the worst country in
the world and kids being born to single
mothers why so so uh so uh uh Biden
comes out and they want to add another
2.6 trillion dollars because they want
to increase the amount of money we're
given to single mothers with kids here's
how the policies got started what caused
this The Surge is based on two things
one in 1935 FDR when it came out with
Social Security he also came out with a
new deal he also came out with policies
to give money to single mothers okay
who had kids okay these are single
mothers maybe they lost a husband War
something was going on but they're like
we have to take care of them fine we
have to take care of them no problem
then in 1965 lb Johnson LBJ takes it to
whole different level and then you see
the skyrocketing and they said here's
how we're going to invest into
eliminating
people being poor the Great Society
Brandon can you send me that one chart
on the flip on what happens if the
investment we made and the amount of
debt we increased to help out the poor
to eliminate the poor brand and if you
know what chart I'm talking about just
text it to me for me to show this to Rob
so Rob can show it up this is not the
one but he'll send it to me right now to
see it it took 55 years for us to find
out that that investment we made in
single mothers became a bad habit and
now it's costing us so much money that
we can't get away from it anymore we're
spending 53 percent in entitlement
programs so going back to what we're
talking about no the other one that
shows Rob the other one that shows the
one that's declining and the other one
that's increasing I think you know which
one I'm talking about uh uh here I'll
send this as well to Rob but the other
one I'll send Rob I want to send this to
you so the audience is watching this
they know where to go get the source to
to do their own research on what we're
talking from four percent to 40. so so
going back to Adam your point about
what's to do there's two things I think
about one is what we can do as
individuals as people that have families
to inspire others yes you got to make
more money yes you got to spend less
money and the way the government can do
it guess what government's gotta also
make more money and they gotta also what
spend less money yeah we keep
spending more money and we're making
less so Middle America's look at this
this is less than four percent of 1950s
you see the person a number of single
unwed birth rates we're above 40 percent
we're at 41 this is not good so by the
way somebody's watching and saying
how do I do do we get off the topic and
are talking about this what happened if
my mother if my mother tried to
discipline me single mother say Hey you
better do this I'm not listening to my
mom what are you talking about no I'm
going out I'll be home at 11 o'clock you
need to be on by this time she can hit
me that gets to an age that the hitting
doesn't hurt anymore and she kind of
sitting there saying what do I do now
you either have to marry somebody to
discipline me or you have to call my dad
but you guys are divorced so you guys
don't talk I'm gonna do whatever the
hell I want to do so out of 1.8 GP in
high school what if there was some order
in the house what if somebody didn't
come into my life to give me I saw a
picture the other day that this
African-American man in school is buying
suits for kids teaching them how to
shake hands teaching them how to take
care of themselves freaking awesome I
want her to find out who this guy was to
buy him a nice suit or two for himself
and take care of him but we need more of
data like this to look at and realize
listen we're screwing this thing up
here's the investment oh my God I can't
wait to show this to you guys Rob I'm
going to text this to you folks if you
see this we have this article that's
going to be coming out here soon this
research we did great job shout out to
Brandon on a great job he's doing with
the research Rob if he can pull this up
so we can show this this next one is the
real one I want you guys to see it shows
like when you invest remember yesterday
I was talking to 401K why aren't you
guys investing into the 401K to match
and all this stuff that we have
short term what do people say uh it's
not what's the big deal I'm not going to
make that kind of money I'm not going to
do this it's just your turn look at this
right here total means tested welfare
spending and official poverty rate from
1947 to 2012. so look at the poverty
like to the left you see how high it was
percentage of people that were poor at
during what era this is great depression
post-great depression okay and the
amount of money we spend on welfare
look at the break even you see when they
cross paths what year is it 1990 yeah
1992 yeah okay 1992 yeah that takes
about 55 years but then guess what
happened the poor level stayed the same
look at our look at our costs for
welfare guys this didn't work
this whole thing about the plan that FDR
came up with ended up being a show
and you and I are paying a price for it
and Lyndon Johnson what did what he did
in 65 that also didn't help look at the
spike after 65. you see 65 so it was
gradual from what FDR did to 65. but
look what happened after 65 boom it just
goes both of them combined we became a
spending machine country and we're not
watching what happened to China and
Japan we are next if we keep going like
this this is a serious issue this is not
a hypothetical when I'm going around
talking a different podcast this last
week I did podcasts a few different part
one podcast I did with Tom Ford I think
his name is Tom Ford from Forbes he says
look I disagree with almost every single
one-year policies obviously he's on the
left and we're having a comment he says
well you know how about this and how
about that and I talked to George jenko
and we're talking to Graham Steph and
George ankle about to get married wants
to have a family grand staff and about
to get married wants to have a family
and this other guy had two daughters
that I'm talking to I said listen I
don't care if you're a Democrat or
Republican this shit's not working
this spending money to try to save
poverty is not working we need to step
out of the way and let people figure it
out four percent to 41 what happens when
most kids are raised by single mothers
boys are going to be doing whatever the
hell they want to do makes make cities
unsafer you can't look at this and say
well that's not fair and that's racist
and that's this and that's that no
problem go back to your problem go back
to your uh what do you call it um
ideas and see what that's done to your
Society you go ahead and do that keep
spending the money see what it does to
you and then one day we're going to wake
up I'm gonna say damn it look at this
stuff but this is proven this is not a
hypothetical this is proven data on what
we did and where we are today and either
we're going to do something about it or
we're not so and Pat you said you're the
first thing if you were in charge it
would be with number one is just stop
printing money I'm going to change
incentives is the first thing I'm doing
okay well like like for instance what
would you want one major one how do you
how how is your life right now how do
you feel right now with yourself your
confidence your personal life right now
I'm good you're good yeah okay what
changes have you made in your life give
dramatic changes you made pre-vt to now
pre-vt um I don't drink
um pre-vt you were drinking of course
okay yeah not like a maniac but you know
I go out I drink I socially Adam was
like
uh drinking obviously going to church
spending money unless stupid stuff I'm
not going out I'm not doing anything
crazy but uh yeah just life is
Everything's changed
everything everything Health different
way you're eating you know the other day
George is like hey why does the vanilla
steroids yeah everybody that's just
hater the first thing we have to do is
we have to change the incentive programs
that we have in America our incentive
program which is our tax system when you
work for a sales company whatever their
comp structure is is going to produce
behaviors our tax system is producing
the behavior of single mothers our tax
system is producing the behavior of not
going after your dreams why because the
government's stealing that away from you
by giving you money so you don't have to
work your ass up to go after your dreams
our tax system is producing
super super super wealthy people and
it's producing the middle class to be
eliminated there is no incentives our
tax system is making the big companies
bigger and the small business owners to
disappear just 40 years ago we have 50
plus companies when we wanted to buy
weapons or we wanted to buy planes
today's those 50 plus companies are five
five we are now with what's going on
today in the economy these bigger banks
are buying the smaller Banks what is
that doing fewer options to go to Banks
as be nationalized the tax system in our
incentive system is destroying the
middle class and the only way to address
that you have to make some dramatic
changes and that is going to infuriate
so many people at the top that have
control so for a person to do that the
current system is not going to be
sustained for a person like that to win
so this is why I kind of like what Vivek
is talking about this is why I like what
rfk's talking about that's why I like
the fact that Trump's pushing the
envelope even The Descent is out there
hopefully they're able to give their
message better tonight tonight or
tomorrow night tomorrow night's going to
be an innovate we're watching it right
we need somebody to come in that can't
be bought that's not for sale there was
a there was a one of the best moments in
the debate
was when Trump and Hillary are going at
it and Anderson Cooper asked a question
and says taxes if he can pull this clip
up I don't know if you know which one
I'm talking about yeah he says hey uh uh
uh Donald uh Mr Trump you know your tax
records show that you paid nothing in
taxes last year you haven't paid taxes
for this many years and he says yeah
absolutely my goal is to pay the least
amount of taxes possible so are all of
her donors yeah and then she said but
here's the thing if Hillary wanted to
fix it how come she hasn't changed that
for 30 years because her donors won't be
happy and this is why I haven't taken a
single penny from the donors because I
can't be bought I can't be controlled
she can't
it it the only reason somebody will
listen to that and say that's
is because you're such a Democrat that
you're not open to the idea of an
opposing argument that logically makes
all the damn sense in the world one
person has bought the other person is
not is this the one that you're talking
about play this money I think this is
the one go ahead and play it on taxes
where the number one issue on Facebook
for the first time the campaign the New
York Times published three pages of your
1995 tax returns they show you claim to
960 million dollar loss which means you
could have avoided paying personal
federal income taxes for years you've
said you pay state taxes employee taxes
real estate taxes property taxes you
have not answered though a simple
question did you use that 916 million
dollar laws to avoid paying personal
federal income taxes of course I do of
course I do and so do all of her donors
or most of her donors I know many of her
donors her donors took massive tax rate
last month yeah it unfortunately doesn't
show the next 30 seconds because you
know she he says if you had 30 years how
come you've not done anything about it
our incentive system right now sucks on
America anyways let's go to the next
topic that we got okay uh
okay let's go to tipping and then from
The Tipping actually you want to go to
Hawaii what do you want to go into
um let's go into tipping and then we'll
go into Hawaii so here we here we go
America's fight over tipping at
restaurants comes to its biggest
Battlegrounds yet this is a Wall Street
Journal story that we have here
uh a battle over tipping at restaurants
is unfolding in Chicago where
discussions are evolving revolving
around the potential transition from the
city's minimum wage to the tipped weight
system for weight staff and other
restaurant workers under the existing
setup large businesses in Chicago pay
tipped employees a minimum of 948 per
hour with tips compensating the
remaining amount activists are pushing
for change arguing that restaurant staff
should be entitled to the same minimum
wage as other workers however restaurant
owners are raising concerns about
potential disruptions to their
businesses especially during a period of
post-inflation recovery and sales losses
due to the pandemic they anticipate
higher price operational costs which
could uh necessitate uh the menu price
hikes and staff reduction so Tom what is
this all about
this is about entitlement the key phrase
restaurant staff should be entitled to
the same minimum pay as other workers in
other words that waiter that knows you
that busts their butt that is watching
everything and delivering everything and
taking care of you and making that
dinner the best it can be you tip tip
stands for to ensure prompt service tips
and it used to be done in advance I'd
like to have dinner here and you slip a
five dollar bill to the waiter and then
you didn't pay at the end and that was
to ensure prompt service so that you let
them know that you appreciate them you
tip ahead now we tip at the end but in
Chicago let me check up blue State
um they are basically saying gosh it's
unfair that the wait staff make this on
the on the minimum wage 948 but the rest
of the restaurant doesn't they're trying
to turn the restaurant into a socialist
we are all equal
organization that's what this is all
about whereas the waiter and the
waitress put their personal style and
their personal attention to earn that
extra that we appreciate uh so it's so
that's basically saying that it's just
lump so now this person is not going to
go above and beyond to do for you
because it's already included in the tip
right it's not going to change yeah yeah
so so you know I'll go to a restaurant
and I'll say uh if a guy goes above and
beyond and also let me ask the question
does this tip go directly to you or does
it go you guys share it will share here
yeah that's okay I'm just going to give
you 20 because I was going to give you
40 but I'm not going to share with
everybody else because I don't know how
well they're doing yeah I tip less if it
goes to everybody versus if it goes to
the individual person I tipless because
then the server think about the
incentive on the server the server is
going to be like why would I go above
and beyond if I know I'm not going to be
sharing the whole thing with everybody
now if you worked at a restaurant before
I've been a busboy before the servers at
the the end of the night will share tips
with the busboy if you're working
running this and they'll share with the
workers on the back Etc et cetera that's
something that they do and they go above
and beyond but for me you want that
individual to have a identity on going
above and beyond for service because
they're going to get better tip from you
if they cut that out what's the motive
for somebody who want to go above and
beyond and what's the motive for
somebody to want to tip above and beyond
those two things are kind of eliminated
yeah I often say some of the best sales
people uh in the world certainly in
America come from the restaurant
industry because they have to learn
service they need to learn how to
communicate effectively to upsell
interpersonal communication to put on a
smiley face even if you're not exactly
in the best mood I was a server all
throughout College I made money and then
boom I got into sales but I think um you
bring a good point about whether they
pull the tips or not I don't really get
into the the details of that I just you
typically tip 20 it is what it is
um I I actually uh fully understand what
you said tips there's actually an
acronym for it tips to ensure prompt
service so it's interesting like that
but tipping is part of our culture in
here in America I remember I went to
Australia for the first time in like
and um I left the tip uh you know I
think I it was a you know 100 bar tab I
left like 20 bucks whatever it was and
my buddy's like mate why'd you why'd you
leave money for the for the server and
I'm like uh tip is like we don't tip
here in Australia these guys make 25 an
hour I'm like what these guys are making
20 this is 2010 29 yeah like what prices
I mean as a server you're making five
bucks an hour and you're relying on tips
to basically eat
um and I was like hold on what's going
on here and then if you go to Europe
that you know tips are maybe 10 at the
most when I was in Israel recently you
know five ten percent shekels it's not a
big deal but tipping is a part of our
culture here in America what's the
typical tip 20 that's just sort of
standard but I think that servers and
anyone that served before understands
how much work you put in being a server
and you just simply cannot get by on
whatever the number is whether it's five
dollars or nine dollars it's minimum
wage it's not it's not uh sustainable
the other thing so I'm fully in in the
server's Corner the other thing that I
actually kind of have an issue with
these days is everywhere you go in
America anything you buy you go to
Starbucks the guy pours your coffee do
you want to add a tip all right you go
to Chicken Kitchen over here all right
you want to add a tip anywhere you go
that you want to add a tip and they
automatically give you uh 15 20 25
option okay so I just bought a
Chicken Kitchen for 16 it's like okay
the lady who did nothing is ringing it
up and she's like looking at you're
staring it's like I hate it it's like
flip the thing on you it's like a
staring contest you're playing Russian
roulette just like just boom boom boom
she's like yeah how much you're gonna
leave as a tip it's like I gotta leave
this lady four dollars and 25 cents
because she rang up my chicken and rice
order it's I'm like so I will take the
second and be like uh add you know your
own tip and I'll say you know two
dollars whatever because I'm just not
gonna leave five dollars every time that
I pick up a Starbucks or pick up a
Chicken Kitchen it's become ridiculous
but this like tipping War it's at I feel
like at a tipping scale right now and
it's interesting to see how it plays out
there's two different problems here the
first problem is Chicago's trying to put
in
um socialist entitlement capitalism is
based on Merit Merit is based on skill
skill style everything the Merit of the
server to deserve and earn earn e-a-r-n
odd word to earn the tip at the end of
the meal and now they're just gonna turn
it where everybody is paid this rate and
you know who's gonna carry that the
restaurant owner now the restaurant
owners got to pay everybody according to
an escalated minimum wage and hope
there's enough pooled tips in there to
do it and if the servers mail it in and
they don't do too much and the own and
the restaurant owner only clears 15
percent average tip she sure this is
going Pat you just took the profit out
of the restaurant owner that's what you
did with this socialist feeling that
everybody should be paid yeah a little
bit more and what's the root word of
being a server it's service so if you
want to go to a good restaurant a nice
restaurant have good service you need to
incentivize the server to provide good
service if they're de-incentify it's
incentivized and they don't give a
we've all been to places where they
don't tip people well or basically
there's no tips required service is
and that's essentially what we're going
through another another thing that
entitlements is going to ruin so there
you go all right let's go to the next
next thing on what's going on in Hawaii
850 people still missing in Hawaii uh uh
after Maui wildfires CNBC the mayor says
it's on page 17 if you want to go there
um
mayor Richard Bisson uh revealed that
850 individuals remain missing after the
devastating Maui wildfires with 114 114
confirmed that's making it the deadliest
modern U.S Wildfire event the mayor
clarified that 27 victims have been
identified while over 1285 people have
been located safely
uh the initial count of over 2 000
people missing decreased due to restored
cell phone communication enabling
contact with loved ones the process of
accurately determining casualties in
Mass disasters can span months or years
as researchers point out emphasizing the
that the final death toll uh remains
provisional in response to the tragedy
the FBI introduced a site for people to
provide DNA samples for expedited victim
identification aiming to Aid the
outgoing effort to match remains with
those reported missing absolutely tragic
rap can you show uh with President Biden
who was on a second vacation for the
month which by the way an article came
up from uh if you want to if you want to
talk about 40 yeah he's been he's been
on vacation for 40 of his presidency
he's living the dream 40 of his
president presidency has been on
vacation God according to uh what is
this thing travel uh nor President
Biden's recent 10-day Delaware Beach
vacation pushes his known vacation days
to 360 days Counting for 40 of the time
dude uh Defenders cite the convenience
of Biden's close to White House trips as
justification echoing a historical
tradition of scrutinizing presidential
vacations criticize critics have
targeted president for leisure
activities since the deception of the
office Biden's Camp David visits nearly
double dose of trump yet fall short of
past presidents like President Bush who
told 150 visits underscoring the ongoing
debate on presidential work life balance
now here's what happened the challenge
is he hadn't shown up and by the way he
kept saying he's going to go to
Palestine Palestine
he went to Hawaii this is the reception
that he got can you please can you show
the clip of the reception he got when he
got there the video I just I think not
this one there's a video I texted you
rob uh uh right is that yeah that's the
one watched this here when he shows up
to Hawaii look at the love he's getting
wow he's finally here yay
wow yeah awesome awesome yeah thanks for
nothing thanks for nothing
you you yeah
you
I love that guy hey right here hey
you Joe you what do they voted for
him that's the problem I'll tell you
something right now just FYI for
everybody uh Hawaii Democratic Iran
State uh Biden won Hawaii 63.7 percent
Tom uh over uh Trump 29.5 margin over
Trump do you guys think that they're
going to be who do you guys think
they're going to vote for this time
around who do you think just think about
it God 100 they're gonna vote for mine
again because you know why Pat they
don't want the mean guy in there the
mean guy that gets the job done and
let's let's just just going backpack
this is the same Administration that let
uh Pete Buda judge go on maternity leave
because they adopted a kid and he was
gone for three months this guy's on
vacation it's not a surprise but let's
get Pat let's get really fast into so
when it comes to the the besides the
president not giving a and he
doesn't he was asleep during uh some of
the speeches he stood there you know how
out of touch he is he was like he was
like boy this ground is hot yeah because
it was on fire for a week you idiot like
people people are dead you know what he
said Rob you you said this before you
walked in here he's in the speech and uh
Rob if you bring it up you know what he
said he goes yeah I could kind of feel
your guys's pain one time lightning
struck outside my house and we thought
the house was going to catch on fire hit
electrical wire electrical Brandon in my
house and he goes you know what I was my
I thought I was going to lose my
Corvette and my cat look how to touch he
is can you play that
I don't want to
compare difficulties but we have a
little sense Jill and I
what it's like to lose a home
years ago now 15 years ago I was in
Washington doing Meet the Press yeah it
is it was a sunny Sunday
lightning struck at home
on a little Lake it's outside of our
home not on a lake a big pond a big pond
not a lake a wire and came up underneath
our home
into the heating Ducks the air
conditioned make a long story short
please I almost lost my wife
my 67 Corvette with had documents in my
cat yeah and his cat walking inside
I watched the firefighters
the way they responded
no there's no expression
I grew up right across the street from a
fire hall in Claymont Delaware
and
how out of touch how out of touch can
you be there's a thousand children still
missing and you're like you know what I
almost my cat and my Corvette almost
were were destroyed but Pat going back
towel with him because he's he's
obviously
completely out of touch and he's too old
the the response and everything that
happened in Maui everybody keeps calling
me conspiracy and I think those guys
have those people have no arguments so
let's just get this straight the guy in
charge of Maui Emergency Management has
no idea about anything about the
management the guy in charge of water
Molly shut the water off because God it
was a spiritual thing God told him so
the electric grid blew down they didn't
shut the power off one of the world's
best emergency siren systems didn't work
Pat just randomly that day it didn't
work Hawaii is surrounded by water it's
just it's it's unbelievable the amount
of like
nobody's doing their job it's all so
then when you say stuff like hey maybe
it's almost like they wanted all this to
go down for for this land grab and Bob
another fun conspiracy fact you know the
police chief he's also the coroner of
that place that's the same the Vegas guy
he's the corner of of of Hawaii the guy
that the Las Vegas guy that was in
charge it's just everything is adding up
and then like I said last time pat for
them to be calling uh real estate people
are calling these poor people and
they're going Hey listen we want to buy
your land please sell to us and then we
give them 700 Pat be honest your house
burns down what is 700 going to do for
you and your family of five yeah but the
government wants to ban out of state
property purchases to stop developers
targeting Wildfire a raved ravaged
Lahaina on pricing locals out so there
there are some of the things that's
going on there it's definitely very
suspicious I won't uh I don't uh I won't
sit there and disagree with that very
suspicious what's going on my my bigger
concern is the water thing very weird
the water thing is very weird where they
save the water have you do you have that
clip Rob where the guy talks about
saving the water instead of doing it for
the fire the equity yeah it's just I
mean what do you mean by you're saving
the water for that instead of people you
know getting killed literally 100
something people are dead well what's
the number 114 114 and then President
Biden gets up there and gives a speech
like like that's the speech I want to
hear after I lost somebody I think about
it imagine you just lost somebody not to
Natural death you lose somebody to
Natural death
yeah totally get it that's a different
kind of a funeral you knew somebody to
addiction to drugs different kind of a
funeral you lose somebody to a disaster
a natural disaster that could have been
saved this is horror
you you now have someone to blame you
now have like the last thing you want is
somebody to come and say my Corvette
almost burned down you know my cat my
cat almost died look this takes me back
to how out of touch he is when when
Martin Luther King got shot RFK came up
and gave a talk and he said look
here's a news Martin Luther King has
just been assassinated and he pauses
lets them kind of go through there are
zero jokes zero you don't tell jokes
when people in front of you lost people
you don't make a comparison to a car of
yours so my concern is more how you
connect with the audience how you
respond as a leader how quickly and
Swift you are to come over there and
you're taking your time to come there
you're not going to win people over like
that and uh but it's been a normal
pattern with them it's not like it's a
first time nobody in America should be
surprised with the way he's responding
to a time do you have any thoughts on
this Hawaii deal yeah I think there's a
speculators were in New Orleans after
Katrina speculators were in Naples
Florida and Space Coast that little town
space coast that was absolutely
obliterated part of the hurricane a year
ago speculators show up and so I think
that people are trying to throw a Log on
the Fire there I set that aside they're
going to show up and I actually think
it's good for the governor to say hang
on nobody is selling anything for right
now Pat I think that's a good move by
the governor nobody is selling anything
let's see if we can get you back on your
feet
I stepped back into it and just say how
does the Emergency Services supposed to
be serving the populace I'm just stunned
that how many of the Emergency Services
failed all at once the police failed on
the evacuation plan once they knew they
had their hands full the sirens the
water all of that failed the speculators
I think the governor is making a good
call there saying nobody's selling
anything you're going to keep your
houses and keep what's going on let's
get you back on your feet but I'm not
worried about right that now finally the
governor is speaking up a little bit
Yeah fine Pat we we said they're gonna
63 well 64 voted Democrat what what is
going on in your head that especially
after a situation like this and the
president doing what he did how do you
still vote for Democrat Tom how how are
you that loyal to a party that is
showing you in real time that they don't
give a about you the day that it
went down they're approving 24 billion
dollars to Ukraine and the people
because mainstream media is barely
showing these people those videos I see
on Twitter were the people of Maui the
people of Hawaii are are sick and tired
of this and you're still gonna vote
Democrat not to be glib but it's uh be
glib it up no it's habit
and habit and addiction
okay
so they're just stuck you're you're
still going to go on them to the
entitlements and it's generations of
habit
and you can't be and you're not willing
to process the difference okay all right
let's move on to the next story so let's
talk debate uh on what's going on
tomorrow did you have thoughts or no
yeah I was just gonna add one thing
um just to kind of give some context to
what's going on here
um why people vote for Democrats
Republicans I think people are fixated
and they're basically
um aligned with their team and that's
just it is what it is and there's ten
percent of Americans that can control
the country and they happen to be in
four or five different cities and we'll
see how the election goes we all know
that but here's um the thing with um
Hawaii in this situation I think every
president has these moments that
um they fail uh George Bush failed with
Katrina uh Donald Trump arguably failed
with Puerto Rico that's still an ongoing
thing right there remember how he took a
lot of criticism on how long it took for
him to respond to the horrible disaster
that that happened in Puerto Rico and
just like uh when George Bush went to
visit Katrina there were people sticking
the middle finger up and giving giving
him that so let's not forget that just
like when Trump went to uh Puerto Rico
and he was shooting jump shots with
toilet paper or paper towels he also
received that backlash and Biden
deserves every ounce of this backlash
because as Pat pointed out he failed and
he did not respond quickly enough and
this is incumbent on President's United
States to respond accordingly I will
also add that when it comes to vacations
uh Biden's the goat it's not even a
question he's killing he's killing the
game right now
um but you know who was actually uh what
president in the last
30 years went on the least amount of
vacations the least take a guess
Trump Obama not even close it was Obama
at 38 Bush went on over a hundred Trump
went on 132 and Biden's at what number
right now in fact 200 and something
right now so the way that they break
vacations down is pretty interesting I
did some research so you have time at
the White House you have time at What's
called the second White House the
vacation house for the White House which
is Camp David in in Maryland then you
also count foreign trips so if you're
not in the White House and you're
traveling to Saudi Arabia or Japan or
Israel wherever it is then you have your
own properties so for Trump it's
Mar-A-Lago it's bedminister New Jersey
for uh Biden he's what in Delaware he's
doing his thing for uh Obama it's
Martha's Vineyard and and um for the
bushes it was what Texas and then also
up in the Northeast somewhere and then
there's actually just full-on vacation
time so every president does it I don't
know about that the the way they're
categorizing it Trump worked out of
Mar-A-Lago Trump didn't want to sleep at
the White House they did he actually
called the White House a dump yeah so
that is not called that is not called
vacation the guy the day he got elected
the next Puerto Rico you may have a
pointer I don't know what the exact
timeline was with Puerto Rico uh but if
there was a guy 2017 that any time a
crisis happened he was there the next
day it's Trump you can't say that about
any of the guys we've had the last
couple decades this guy showed up the
next day it doesn't matter where the
crisis was it was always available never
turned down an interview never turned
out going to meeting with anybody else
that was not an area where he was
uncomfortable with he was never afraid
of
uh controversy or opposition that's not
one of his flaws he's got many flaws
that's not the flood the guy gets
elected the next day he's at the office
interviewing people for jobs yeah who
the hell does that he got elected the
next day he's at the White House doing
interviews with people Romney came in
all those videos about different he's
not even waiting you know most people
take a month after all this other stuff
there's one guy that they can't talk
about not working it's this guy he went
to didn't go visit East Palestine and uh
Biden everything didn't he go and visit
the border and Biden never did I mean
this guy went everywhere while he's not
the president and the other guys are
just kicking and not going to different
places while Crisis crisis is happening
even Obama didn't go to places and he's
an ex-president and Trump's an
ex-president he's still paying a visit
by Obama's playing a very different game
today than Trump is Trump is still in
the game you can't compare work ethic
between those two guys Biden needed
Obama needed a home to sleep at the
White House Trump's got 50 homes in
different places to go visit but I
understand your point on possibly Puerto
Rico and some of the other things okay
um
Trump has already recorded his debate
night counter program and interview with
Tucker Carlson sources say 11 page 11.
so sources say he's already recorded his
uh interview with Tucker Carlson where's
I went there okay okay so former
president strategically recorded an
interview with the X Fox News host
Tucker Carlson earmarked as counter
programming for the forthcoming GOP
Presidential debate he has chosen to
abstain from Trump's aim to skip the
debate while engaging in an alternative
discourse as he will be at his Club in
Bedminster Jersey the night of the
debate according to Trump's senior
campaign adviser Jason Miller trumps
confidence in his popularity and
accomplishments was evident in a true
social post last Thursday where he
justified his absence by stating people
know my record one of the best ever so I
would I why would I debate I'm your man
make America great again and another
story comes up from WS J Trump holds a
23-point lead over DeSantis in Iowa the
Iowa poll highlighted that Trump's
commanding 23-point lead over Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis in the Republican
Presidential nominating contest with 42
percent of the likely caucus goers
favors Trump and 19
supporting the scientists so thoughts on
him not doing the debate I have a
different kind of a thought on him not
doing a debate in like in Olympics when
you qualify for the Olympics or like a
team makes it to the play you don't you
rest you bench your your star players
you don't want them to get hurt why why
would you go in there and go through all
this when you're already number one I
think it's smart I think it's tactical
and you know why why go out there and
waste all your all your ammunition when
you you're already in first place you
know I mean I don't think I think I
think him going up there and messing up
what hurt him in the eyes of the people
and like he doesn't want to waste his
time I think I think this is actually a
good move it's kind of funny you know we
get into the playoffs and professional
sports and the best teams get a bye week
and I think what he's just saying here
hey I'm going to take the bye week and
let these people go through the
preliminary playoffs on their own which
is effectively what's happening here
there's a side of me that wants to see
him go out and clear the decks and be
the man that he is and to lay it on the
line and clear the decks there's a part
of me that wants to do that but there's
another part of me that understands he's
like look this is the preliminary part
of the playoffs here I'm taking a bye
week yeah I fully agree with the bye
week situation he's in first place he
deserves to you know sit this first
debate out I don't actually don't think
this debate would actually help him too
much in the polls I think if he did show
up you would have knives out from Mike
Pence Chris Christie uh DeSantis for
sure the list goes on and if you take
some uh Friendly Fire let's say it would
not be exactly a good look for Trump on
that regard I think he's
almost a shoe-in to be the candidate for
the Republican nomination I think this
would not help him uh I think he's
making a good decision by sitting this
out he's gonna go get a ton of eyeballs
on Tucker and uh and do that thing uh by
the way also shout out to Jason Miller
our buddy uh kind of holding down the
fort and Trump Camp I like that guy a
lot so I'll go with that where's the
where's the Twitter uh is the uh
Tucker thing going to be on Twitter
where is that going to be yeah he's
going to post them all this Tucker stuff
is on Twitter Tucker's show is on
Twitter how much number how many numbers
you think if you have to guess how many
numbers are going to want easily 100
million plus because musk is going to
retweet it easily 100 million plus wow
what are your thoughts do you think this
is a good move that Trump is not uh
going to this debate what do you think I
think timing wise is like all this
only reason I would say make sense for
him to sit it out is timing wise because
they're trying to go arrest him do all
of that stuff now okay so he's not gonna
have enough time to
see reactions he's a counter puncher so
he kind of wants to see what the
Market's going to say he doesn't like
surprises not that he's not going to do
bad with surprises they're going to try
to surprise him with a lot of different
things he'll come out attacking so go
through each let's just say he was on
the debate stage let's play it okay go
through each one of them
um he will put Mike in his place within
seconds Mike will be relevant he's the
only guy in the last seven months since
January whose Twitter following has
decreased since he's talking about pants
right says the only guy whose Twitter
following has decreased the fly on his
head has more followers I heard the fly
yeah was on the last time so what is he
going to do to go to the next person
Chris Christie Chris Christie's gonna
say a couple things Chris Christie's
probably going to get under Trump's skin
and he'll piss him off a little bit so
he's probably doesn't want to deal with
Chris Christie that's probably the most
yeah he's the one that helped him
prepare for the debate yeah he knows
what he's doing so Chris Christie's
gonna probably be the annoying one but
still he would get this Trump's going to
have Trump's going to get the comeback
on him and then who else you got outside
Tim Scott Tim Scott is nice nothing's
gonna happen
the santis he's uh he's gonna go after
the santis vivek's not going to do
anything at uh him no and then am I
missing somebody I feel like I'm missing
whatever vanilla uh Suarez I don't know
if he's gonna be in it I think it's
gonna be I'd love to see him though yeah
we'd love to see him yeah he's hit the
numbers ASA Hutchinson and then also who
has the uh the other guy which the
governor North Dakota what is the guy's
name uh yeah so it's okay so let's let's
transition into the debate so give
predictions what do you think is going
to happen with the debate who do you
think is going to come out who do you
think is going to be like you know if
you're just looking at this right now
give your one two three four give who's
gonna come out surprising with the plus
minus meaning this person's gonna have a
plus that person's gonna have a minus
this person's gonna stay neutral and
xyze is going to have the biggest plus
how would you rate it wow okay I think
vivec number one is going to be the star
what we've biggest plus I think the
biggest plus is gonna be Vivek he's just
I mean from being on our town hall this
guy is everywhere and I've listened to
as much content as I can he is an
encyclopedia of knowledge and his
attitude and his family he's Mr G I
think he's gonna go he'll be number one
wow I think Tim Scott uh number two uh I
love his attitude he doesn't give a damn
he just tells it how would it
um descent I don't know dude three
uh I would say yo Chris Christie I put
Chris Christie because he has a big
attitude three I would put him at three
because what I don't think the Santa's I
don't think the Santos is gonna have
that fire but I haven't seen anything
from the Santa it's the only time I've
seen the santis with that little
attitudes when you're trying to act like
Trump with the media during during covet
I put Tim Scott I put Christy then I put
uh the Santas I think it'll be later on
in the debate so try to get a little bit
Rob why don't you run a poll how many
names can you put on the poll just to
see what the audience can say is it four
can you do five six
see tell me if it's more than four then
I'll give you the name so so Pat Vivek
uh
vivec Scott
Christy uh DeSantis Adam Haley so uh
we can do four well then if it's four do
Vivek to the santis to Tim Scott we want
to do Christy or Pence I think Chris I
think you put Pence for sure she's not
gonna be easy and then and then Christy
not Tim okay well that's my opinion you
think so okay why don't you do Tim Scott
Chris Christie Vivek and DeSantis but go
ahead damn Penn State former VP can't
even make it number one I think
um Vivek is an absolute Superstar I
think he's gonna
hold his own for sure on that stage but
I've said it before and I've said it
again I think his ceiling is uh is
pretty low just because uh if you're
trying to win the Mike Pence white
Christian Evangelical vote I think
they're gonna have a hard time voting
for a brown Hindu boy uh I just think
that's my opinion and but by the way
you're not alone there a lot of people
are with you there just just by the way
I would vote for that guy in an instant
so this is not a self-reflection by the
way if he would never do it but if he
did run as a Democrat he would be Obama
straight up
but with business Acumen so maybe uh so
you're thinking Republicans will not
embrace them I I don't think the base of
the Republican party will certainly Maga
uh I think DeSantis is going to do his
thing straight up I think DeSantis has
been prepared for this I think he's
ready for this I think uh he's Gonna
Shine and he doesn't
um necessarily have Trump coming after
him there so we all forget about
DeSantis that he was neck and neck with
Trump about six months ago and I think
he's going to his thing and then I'll
give you my sleeper North Dakota
governor his name is Doug uh bergam and
uh he runs on three things he talks
about American independence he talks
about
um getting out of debt and he just talks
about uh American greatness and he just
kind of stays in his Lane he does his
thing he's a great communicator so I
think he's a sleeper guy I think that
Tim Scott has got no chance I think Mike
Pence has got no chance I think Chris
Christie's got no chance I think that
Nikki Haley's vying for a potential uh
VP role and uh you know they're just
going to clear the field and at the end
of the day it's gonna be Trump DeSantis
Vivek and whatever cast of characters
isn't this basically the vice president
well no here's the thing you have to
realize guys I mean the the thing about
from my experience last 20 years I've
not been in politics for last however
many years it's been 20 years yeah a lot
how many times do you see a walker oh
he's gonna do this and then boom oh he's
Marco Rubio
oh you know so you you don't you you
don't know I mean at this point John
Kerry should have been president Romney
should have been president God knows how
many people should have been president
this thing is very hard and don't forget
Herman Cain 999 he went up to 8 18 Newt
Gingrich one to twenty one percent Ross
per one to 19 so there's a lot of stuff
that could happen and couple these guys
behind closed doors have been preparing
the most the one that's been having the
biggest sparring match of going out
there doing his thing is vivec you got
to give that guy credit go ahead Tom
so I look at a couple things here I
think that Chris krincy is going to go
on that stage and surprise a lot of
people he's bold he's Brash he can be
very he he looks like the guy you want
in your corner when the chips are down
you know and so I think there'll be a
little bit of perception on that so I
think he's going to do well I think
Pence completely out the door nothing
will change there I think Scott and
Nikki Haley will be tied with wow what
an interesting smart person I think
America will get introduced to Francis
Suarez there'll be some people say wow I
can see how Miami's turned around that
guy seemed kind of smart but I I don't
think it'll come up above radar I think
this is Vivek and DeSantis that's what I
think is at the top of this thing so Tom
when you say this is Santa's is going to
be over prepared and he is going to take
shots from everybody and we're going to
find out if he's a counter puncher Chris
Christie's a counter puncher if Chris
Christie took the kind of shots that
everybody's gonna throw at DeSantis I
think it would surprise me I think Chris
Christie can fight back in that kind of
okay a debate here's a question for you
which of them you think is going to be
targeting each other at the stage which
of them you think is going to go after
Trump which of them you think is going
to go after uh Biden vivek's not going
to go after Trump Vex going to go after
DeSantis and the vet will blunt
um I think Christy and Scott that I
think is his Playbook Christy is going
to go after Trump and then he's going to
try to blunt DeSantis what do you think
the Santos is going to do
I think DeSantis is going to be over
prepared try to get us talking no no I
got that Tom you think the sentence is
going to go after Trump Biden or Vivek
DeSantis should just go after the
DeSantis is going to go after Biden but
he's also going to go after Vivek and
try to blunt him because he's got
momentum and no Trump you don't think
he's in the Santa's gonna talk about
Trump I don't think DeSantis needs to
talk about Trump I think that's what his
people think he's not on the stage don't
need to talk about him only defeat the
people that are there what do you think
uh I think uh DeSantis is 100 going to
go after Trump after this listless
vessel you know Maga you saw the stat
that that most a percentage I'll let you
give the numbers that uh now uh Revere
Trump more than Jesus shout out to you
guys out there that think that way
um so it's uh it's interesting I think
DeSantis is going to go straight towards
Maga he's going to need Maga but he's
going to try to you know Pierce that
situation but I think that that
um Christy should try to punch I'm sorry
sorry um the Santa should try to punch
up but not punch down Vivek is an
oncomer but I don't think he has the uh
the upside that DeSantis has so and the
rest of them are sort of irrelevant tell
us a question I don't want to counter
what you said but I want to process
something because we've all kind of said
it how does the scientists go after
Trump but also win the Mega voter
yeah that's we're about to find out yeah
that's why I don't think he's going to
go after him hard I think he's got to go
win the match too late it's no he's he's
in too deep listen when you come out and
you know like this Dylan Dennis Scott
which we'll get into with the Logan Paul
and Jake Paul when you put one pick
what's his name Dylan Daniels yeah what
nationality is he by the way Latino is
he okay so when when you post a picture
of a guy once you can't delete it you're
in he's American okay then you go second
third fourth so the santis has already
taken shots at Trump it's not you can't
go back now and play well I changed my
mind I actually have a lot of respect
and admiration for him
I don't know if you guys saw what Trump
posted yesterday on his Instagram
account and his true Social account he
posted a video of all the times DeSantis
spoke highly about Trump did you see
that brilliant everything that the sen
the Santa said that was good about uh uh
uh uh Trump he put it up then he says hi
I'm Donald Trump and I endorse this
message right yeah so he's playing that
game which is great but I want to read
this uh uh what he called Trump's
campaign bills DeSantis as listless
vessels remark as deplorables moments
similar to what Hillary Clinton had but
uh here's uh uh Rob I think it may even
be better if you just play the clip than
me reading all this stuff the Trump
campaign criticized Florida's governor
Ron DeSantis comparison of Republican
supporting Trump to list this vessels if
you have it just play it liking it to
Hillary Clinton's deplorables comment
the sentence made the comment in an
interview with the Florida standards
saying if we all are listless vessels
that are just supposed to follow
whatever happened to come down the
Powell on Truth social every morning
that's not going to be a durable
movement Jason Miller a trump advisor
Drew parallels stating on X looks like
Ron de sanctimonious just had his basket
of deplorables moment not good Trump
campaign spokesperson Stephen chunk said
the sentence is now running the same
failed Playbook as Hillary Clinton uh go
ahead and play it we we have a strand in
our in our party that views
supporting Trump as whether you are
um a rhino or not and so you could be
the most conservative person since
sliced bread unless you're kissing his
rear end they will somehow call you a
rhino so it's been totally detached from
principle and what you actually believe
and results and it's more about you know
just what faction you happen to do so
there'll be people who are huge Trump
supporters like in Congress who have
like incredibly liberal left-wing
records that that's really just
atrocious and yet they're viewed as by
by some of these folks as like as like
really really good then you have other
people you know like a congressman chip
Roy who's endorsed me Congressman Thomas
Massey these guys have records of
principal fighting the swamp that are
second to none and yet they will be
attacked by some of these people and and
called rhinos so it's just been totally
detached from any type of substance and
ultimately a movement can't be about the
personality of one individual School the
movement has got to be about what are
you trying to achieve on behalf of the
American people and that's got to be
based in principle because if you're not
rooted in principle uh if all we are is
listless vessels that's just supposed to
follow you know whatever happens to come
down the pike on Truth social every
morning that that's not going to be a
durable movement Adam
uh well if you look at the definition of
listless do you know what listless means
nobody's behind the wheel no it actually
means uh lacking energy or enthusiasm or
having ready wait for it pat lethargy
okay so I'm being lethargic so if
there's one thing you'll say about the
Maga crowd they are not listless they
are fired up they love their Trump
um that's their guy it's you know some
may say that it's a cult of personality
uh but they are anything but non-uh
energetic that's for sure and a lot of
them are pissed off they're scorned uh
and they have every right to be at the
same time I also do agree with what the
scientist is saying is that even if
Trump wins four years later if you're
just in this tribal Cult of
personalities who's your guy you know
four years ago you loved Mike Pence now
you hate him two years ago you loved
Rhonda sanctimonious now you hate him so
if everything with Maga is just with
Trump what's next so I do think that
um
Ron DeSantis sort of screwed up in this
this was his deplorables moment but uh
if if it is all just based on Trump if
it's all just based on Trump's
personality what's the next four years
look like once Trump is out so is it uh
don Jr is it Ivanka who knows so that's
what that's but by the way you're right
in the area of there are those that
don't see him being able to do anything
right for example this article comes out
CBS News poll shows Trump voters trust
Trump more than family and religious
leaders indictments have become a
rallying Factor CBS poll reveals Rob if
you can pull this up despite facing
legal challenges former president Donald
Trump maintains a strong lead in every
poll
voters have rallied around Trump even
amid multiple indictments with 38
perceiving the indictment as politically
motivated against him Trump supporters
have expanded with 62 percent of likely
Republican primary voters favoring him
up from 61 in June while Governor
DeSantis stands at 16 notably 71 percent
of trump supporters trust him more than
family friends or religious leaders
believing that he tells them generally
the truth Trump supporters emphasizing
their reasons for backing him I believe
that things are better under his
administration his advocacy for people
like them 95 and their familiarity with
him so there is a community there but
I'm going to give you a purely from the
strategy standpoint
uh we moved here because of Governor
DeSantis okay my family is here because
the governor Ron DeSantis uh I moved
this is the only state where we moved
I'm going to keep saying this where I
moved my wife my kids my dad and my
sister I never moved my family to Texas
I could have done it in a heartbeat I
never moved my family to Texas and when
Paula would say I would say I wouldn't
move here I don't know if I'm going to
be here long term I'm just telling you I
wouldn't move you I was just straight up
I'm not one that says hey move let's do
this I don't know I changed my mind and
then now you're screwed with all the
money you spend now let's go to the next
place because I'm gonna do what's best
for me don't move here I may not be here
long term but I'm gonna move
and Florida is no I'm here credit goes
to him so sometimes for example
sometimes
you have a player you like a lot and you
want to see this player make the
decisions you want him to make that
maybe you would have made okay and it's
kind of unfair to the player but also
that's the relationship of a fan
supporter and a player for example
so I like uh uh I really want to see
what Zion Williamson's gonna do to the
point where I invest into his most
expensive card I own it I have it it's a
beautiful card I like it do I like the
way Zion lives his life absolutely not
what I like to see him change the way he
lives his life a hundred percent am I
disappointed that this guy has played
less games in his first whatever three
and a half years some dado showed less
than Greg oh what was Greg Odom number
one yeah what are you doing and you're
going out there getting porn stars
pregnant like who what you're not
listening to him so okay you know what
yeah yeah I'm not gonna so even though
I'm in a half a million yeah okay even
I'm like I'm in in this guy I'm like you
know what screw this I don't like the
way you're doing certain things so there
is a logic to saying dude I wish if this
guy would have made better decisions he
could be an MVP candidate averaging 30.
he's a 30 10-6 guy you don't find a lot
of 30 10 success he's a better version
of the version of the guy from Blake
Griffin he can be a better blade Griffin
he can be like a Barclay slash you know
43-inch vertical leap with a massive
body that he has but I'm not happy with
the way he handled himself okay I got
four kids
I want to see my kids do well they make
bad decisions I don't support their
decisions I'm not sitting there saying I
like the decision you made the part that
is is uncomfortable with me and the
scientists is again logically on every
single golf score he leads the way if I
have to pay any of these candidates to
have somebody lead with the right
policies who can go deep on knowledge
the sentence is my number one guy way
ahead of trump way ahead of uh what do
you call it uh they had in pants they
had way ahead of any of these guys but
I'll give you the other part if I have
to based on working with people in sales
the last 23 years when I sit down with
somebody who's pompous you know how you
feel pompous energy very quickly you you
feel the energy of somebody that just
thinks they're better than you they're
smarter than you and by the way
most of the time they may be so it's not
like they're not they're maybe Tom is
yesterday I said the story I think it
was saying it to Peter or somebody
upstairs in a meeting I said listen when
he comes on to raising Capital if
somebody calls me and says hey Pat I
want to put a pitch deck together and I
want to raise money who should I hire
would be David Consulting not me go talk
to Tom Tom's the best guy to learn how
to write a pitch deck Tom's done a
couple billion dollars of raising money
Capital exits Tom's a guy to talk to I'm
not the guy you should talk to when it
comes down to the details of Lords Tom
one time he did something that was so
interesting we're on a call with lawyers
he says Pat you need to know this if
they use these three words on a call
with you they're asking for this just be
ready we do a call they use one of those
three words we get off the call just
letting you know this call is coming up
they're going to try to do XYZ reprice
Papa be ready for the zoom I'm in Monaco
we get on the zoom 20 plus people are on
the call and it goes in that direction
what do I say on the call
guys uh just so you know I'm not
interested if we move any of the stuff
that's here I'm out just letting you
guys know I'm not interested okay great
fair enough we're gonna stay where we're
at no problem we got off the phone
everybody called me saying I don't know
if I would have ever done what you did
because you just cost yourself maybe you
risk 50 to 100 million dollars I don't
know if I would have done it that way I
don't know if you remember that call
with Greg you know Mark you know bunch
of people we had to call together with
but that's Tom Tom's specialty is that
if you want to raise Capital go talk to
Tom however
then there is the ability to sell the
dream
sell the cause sell the audience you
know you know when uh uh of for example
you know when
you have a friend like I'm you know I've
gone through this in different phases of
my life and it's kind of annoying when
you go through because you hope this
doesn't happen
um
there Comes A Time in your life where
you're competing where you're at the
same level as a couple of your peers
co-workers
and let's just say it's comedy let's
just say it's Insurance let's just say
it's party life let's just say it's
marriage let's just say it's parents or
business or whatever
and this is the one area where you have
to be very careful on what happens here
and all of a sudden one of the comedians
gets a job on a movie yeah instead of
celebrating for your friend you secretly
become envious let me tell you it will
not be a secret for too long it will be
felt
let's say we're doing different podcast
talents here we're about to we made
Seven offers last week two different
talents we'll see which one's gonna end
up working out but we made Seven offers
last week to Talent one came on board
one's going to come in the next week or
two he's starting but we got another
seven that we made offers for let's say
we start doing this if any what if all
of a sudden you get to six million
subscribers and you're blown up
if Adam is secretly envious
that's a problematic issue let's just
say Adam all of a sudden takes off and
he goes to six million that's not Adam's
DNA but let's just say Adam goes to 6
million subscribers and it shows popping
and you're like I don't like the fact
let's just say Tom beats both of you
guys yeah and this doctors takes off
vice versa
in life certain people are going to have
levels of success above others that you
eventually have to say like I had a
friend of mine Steve avettian dude I
want it so bad to be a good basketball
player I freaking sucked but you know
what it was dude I loved watching Steve
play yeah I would ask my dad that I
would see him one someone I would say
dad even though we only have one day to
spend time together can can come down to
Glendale you have to watch this guy play
He's The Armenian Michael Jordan wow we
would sit there and watch Steve play it
was freaking awesome when I watch his
highlight videos I'm freak I get the
chills all over my body when I heard
armored my friend went to Cal State Long
Beach got a degree in mathematics became
a professor at freaking Pasadena
Community College two guys that you
would have never thought doing what
they're doing and then now he's running
the operations of the number one Persian
restaurant in the world him and his
family what he's done with rafi's play I
freaking love seeing celebrating their
successes it's a great feeling the other
day these two Armenian guys came to
family you know the basketball player
who I said I hope you're able to do a
few different from things to get into
the NBA play for the Clippers hit the
shots you know who I'm talking about we
want to have lunch with these guys man I
love seeing these guys play but guess
what some people are better than you so
where is the challenge here
man some of these guys that are trashing
Trump wish
they can be loved and enamored the way
he is by his following and they're so
envious because they cannot replicate
that so when you say you know when it
comes on to voting hasn't can it cannot
be around the personality of the
individual no it is
you have to sell the dream it is around
your personality you can try to dodge
out all you want to run the country it
is forget about Biden Biden's an anomaly
on how he became a president the only
reason Biden's the president is he was
fourth place in Iowa caucus or New
Hampshire one of those where he was
fourth place he was in New Hampshire not
first the president was fourth in New
Hampshire how the hell are you fourth
and a last-minute calls made behind
closed doors on Tuesday Peach drops Amy
drops Elizabeth Warren drops and Bernie
who was ahead like he was doing good and
many these guys dropped to get behind
Biden who made that phone call that's
not capitalism that's not free market
that's somebody can control so Biden's
not a president because he is got the
qualities of being a President Biden the
president because the people behind him
said pick that guy he's the president
will control him for four years it is
what it is take him out Obama sold the
dream Clinton sold the dream Bush was
able to sell the dream and Al Gore sold
the nightmare go to Bush Senior could no
longer sell the dream he was so much
about I'm a better policy guy I'm a
director of CI I'm a this guess what
America said I don't relate to you
Ronald Reagan sold the dream Jimmy
Carter sold the nightmare John F Kennedy
sold a dream if you can't sell the dream
you are not going to get the job of the
number one guy unless if behind closed
door somebody gets indicted and gets
arrested it's not going to happen so my
challenge so to the Santa's Camp if
there if anybody from their Camp is
watching this few basic tips if I'm
talking to Ron look at the camera and
talk to the American people and sell me
the dream
tell me what I'm concerned about earlier
I challenged Adam a little bit when he's
talking to only the single crowd talk to
me if I'm married with kids talk to me
about my concerns when I'm praying with
my kids last night talk to me about my
stresses with my wife and I when we're
arguing at night about we got to take
our kids out of public school because
we're uncomfortable with the stuff
that's happening in different schools
talk to me for the worries that we have
what's going to happen with these
interest rates seven percent I can't
afford to buy a house car prices are 20
times talk to me
talk to me sell me the dream why the
future looks bright why America is the
greatest country in the world why we
cannot lose to these other guys China
and all these no matter what they think
they're doing we are the country that
has led the way for the world sell me
the dream
sell me the dream talk to me not in a
scripted fashion just damn it talk to me
set aside the card set aside the
teleprompter speak from your heart talk
about the fact when you were a kid and
growing up and how you had to overcome
certain challenges and eventually became
who you became today the American people
want to be sold to dream so a lot of
these guys that are going out there
talking the reason why Vivek is creating
so much momentum is because he's selling
a dream
everybody else is bitching at each other
Chris Christie's not going to be the
president why because he's trying to
beat you he's trying to beat you Vivek
is selling the dream
Mike Pence wants a job or he wants to
seek revenge you ain't gonna be a
president seeking Revenge you're just a
freaking Pawn on a chess table nobody
likes you from the other side they're
just using you and they're winning Tim
Scott potentially could have a job on
the administration but maybe he's kind
of shown up to say I want to win the
championship in 2028. I want to be a
future president then show up Tim show
up sell us the dream but I think the
scientists got to come up and say hey
I'm your guy here's who I am this is
your opportunity Ron because if Trump
was there 30 percent of the minutes
would be spent with Trump show up thank
God Trump is not there for DeSantis
because I think this is his only chance
to steal the show if he doesn't it's
over because the next debate Trump's
going to show up in the snow everyone's
going to Target Trump because whether
it's going to be CNN MSNBC or Fox the
board is going to say you better ask the
most questions from Trump because that's
what get gets us the eyeballs people
coming to watch a debate for Trump
they're not coming to watch it for
everybody else so guess what you just
lost 22 minutes you just lost an
addition 11 minutes use your minutes
wisely
use your minutes wisely talk to me sell
the dream I believe I'm telling you this
with this debate that's coming up
tomorrow Milwaukee
I believe this is the chance to make a
comeback and the comeback show has to be
tomorrow if you're able to talk to my
heart more instead of just my brain Ron
you talk to people's brain a lot most
people don't make decisions with their
brains talk to my heart speak to my
heart speak to me with what I'm going
through if you can tug at my heart and
get me to say freaking amen you know
what he ain't perfect he ain't this he
ain't that but I gotta tell you I just I
like that I relate to you know I like
him then he's gonna have a plus minus
tomorrow following day and then go and
do the 50 podcasts that you haven't done
you know how many podcasts Vivek has
done already 60 plus
60 plus he's done you know how many
podcasts some of these other guys have
done I don't know how many podcasts
they've done this guy's done 60 plus and
he keeps climbing and he's selling the
dream so
um
we're gonna learn a lot tomorrow and I
hope some of these guys show up uh I
would love to see Ron make a massive
vertical leap tomorrow
but I don't know who's in his ear and I
don't know what they're telling him I
think he needs to spend a couple hours
today in the bathroom away from
everybody just talking to himself
literally talking to himself reflecting
writing notes why are you doing this Ron
go back to that instead of I have to
prove him and I have to no today it's
you and one other person you know who
the other person is Ron the American
people
it's you and them one-on-one
if you win there
you're gonna have a spike and that 46
point lead that Trump has maybe goes
down to 31 or 32 or 33 and then you go
on 50 60 80 100 different podcasts in
like three months the next six months
not gonna be easy it's gonna be a lot of
work and people are going to say this
guy's a human being I relate to him I
can do them because if you don't
Trump's going to be the candidate and
it's going to be over I agree I think
staying up that amazing you you put it
perfectly like that's what I think he's
missing Pat is a person like you sitting
down with them this entire time and
telling him the hell with the script
look at the American people you can look
in the camera and like you said Pat
looking at people's hearts think about
his story his childhood the the military
working with the Navy Seals his wife
having cancer beating it there's the
story what he did with Colvin yeah the
hell with everybody else just talking to
the person I think is like mind you Pat
if he had you this entire time it'd be a
whole it'd be neck and neck but he has
it he has it like he has a fire you
don't he I've seen this guy freaking
fight and I love it show up look
you know there are those that are 100
Trump okay there are those that are 100
the centers there are those that are 100
anti-republican so it doesn't matter if
it's Biden or anybody they're just
anti-republican I'm not talking to you
there are those that are kind of like
look man I honestly don't want to vote
for Biden I'd like to vote for somebody
else can Republicans just give me
another option outside of trump okay
those guys that are like I'm willing to
vote for somebody else just not Trump
because I don't think okay there are
those that want RFK but they don't
believe RFK is going to be there at the
end but but but the point the point here
is this guy's shown fight
he's got it he just sometimes sounds
like he talks to people he talks at
people stop talking at people man talk
to me stop preaching at me just talk to
me speak to me pause tell me a story
connect with me that's all I want from
you do that you're smart you're
brilliant your background is sick but
that's the one area you need to address
so you dresses it's going to be good I
want to hit one more story before we
wrap up unless if you guys got any 15
second comments
I think Rhonda Sanders needs to watch
that clip on DVD right now listen Maybe
in the bathroom by himself maybe in four
years but David Consulting will offer
campaign Consultants stay tuned all
right maybe so let's go uh let's go to
the next thing here so this whole thing
with Logan Paul and Jake Paul
I want to kind of go into this uh and by
the way I don't want to get into the
Dylan Dennis guy with the pictures
although that's a mess that he's posting
all the pictures of Logan Paul's girl
that he's a uh uh he uh talking about
the engagement and all that stuff he's
posting all these pictures and he's got
a picture that he says if I post this
it's game over I may even go to jail I
may get in trouble and he said he shared
a picture with Andrew Tate and Andrew
Tate retweeted and he says look I've
been following Dylan Dennis all the
stuff he's saying about Logan if he does
share this picture it is going to be
ugly and yesterday Dylan said if I get
to 2 million followers on Instagram I'm
gonna post it I think it's at 1.9
million followers I don't know where
he's at so he posted before the fight I
think he just landed in London it's
going to be ugly but here's the one I
want to talk about Logan Paul and Jake
Paul Rob do you have the clip of Logan
and Jake Paul arguing over Nick Diaz and
arguing over uh you didn't bring the
drink in and you didn't let me say so
what get over it you know sometimes you
just like to play both sides and all
this stuff they're going back and forth
yeah I want to give my thoughts on there
and I want to get your thoughts as well
if you have that clip
of of uh the two of them that that's the
one right there but it it's got to be a
shorter one it's not giving it to you
just type in Logan and Paul just type in
Logan and Jake that's all you have to
type in just type in Logan Jake no no
not and take the word and out like I'm
yeah that's all right just put Logan
Jake there you go so so if we see what
pops up uh that's not gonna go a little
higher on media go higher go higher go
higher
um and I wish we had this prepared
because I really had a couple thoughts I
wanted to share it's not your fault Rob
I didn't tell you about this it's my
fault because just break down pat there
he's arguing because yeah but because
his brother Logan walked into the the
stadium to his fight which he was told
contractually you cannot come in with
any product but Logan they stopped them
Pat and they said you can't come in here
with your with your Prime drink and his
brother's like I'm your brother it's a
contract you were told not to he goes
yeah but it's he was like I found it I'm
texting it to you go ahead he's like but
I'm a businessman and he goes yeah but
listen I am your brother it's not like
it's my decision we have a branding
they're spending millions of dollars you
can't bring in I'm sorry there's a
stipulation that you can't bring in
let's give it a video yeah so and Pat
but think about it as a brother you
can't you're my brother you can't do it
so if you if you look at the video I
just texted you to them first play the
first one that I send you with the drink
wrap I texted both of you guys I text
both of them to you uh yeah that's the
one first if you can play that first
okay so here's what happened Logan and
Jake have a big fallen out apparently a
fallen out over a podcast they did
together and the world is reacting to
this obviously this whole mess that's
going on with Dylan Dennis posting the
pictures of his ex and not his ex his
current fiance that he engaged to and
she's dated all these different guys the
way Donald's put in what's her name her
name is Nina Agdal actually know her
very well she's from Miami oh really
okay fantastic I could go down the path
here as long as you want me to go okay
by the way say that on sauce cast Okay
so so now so you so here's the part so
here's the part where this so Dylan is
saying if I get to 2 million I'm going
to post a picture if the world sees that
they're going to go crazy Andrew Tate
sees the picture and he says if he does
this guy's going to get in trouble
here's the exchange between Logan and
Jake go ahead and play this I would get
kicked out if I brought a prime bottle
to the stadium that's ridiculous
dude yeah get over it meanwhile mom your
brother building oh yeah you you're my
brother building a business you love to
play Both Sides
you play Both Sides what is that you
want to partner with Dana White in KSI
life is my life your life is your life
I'm gonna take these opportunities when
we as brothers no longer become additive
to each other and it feels like you or I
are trying to take from one another but
when it's convenient for you we're
brothers but then when it's not you do
the exact opposite of like we're
completely separate so like I'm gonna do
what I'm gonna do as well I don't know
if I always have to yield and bend my
personal ways because we are brothers
and that's the sole reason they said so
not played the other one that I texted
you the other one is what uh he says
Logan says about out the fight that he
turned down with uh he was supposed to
fight Diaz Rob if you have it uh is this
the one okay good so if you can play
this clip here this is with him talking
about go ahead Fury's on my radar you're
not even a fighter you do exhibitions
and lost like four years ago I thought
better than you and I think Nate chose
you for a reason and I think everyone
knows that but what have you done to
prove that you're better than me I don't
know went Toe to Toe eight rounds with
the greatest boxer of all time if for
whatever reason my favorite story of
avenging my business partner and brother
is right there I think you just I think
you just want to beat Tommy to be able
to say that you're better than me at
boxing time so here's my thoughts on
this couple things uh 80 of me thinks
they're full in the world eighty percent
of me thinks they're full in the world
that this is not real eighty percent you
ever seen the movie Warrior with Tom
Hardy and Nick Nolte
the two brothers that the the guy in the
movie the stories about the guy that
gives five million dollars Winner Takes
all the baddest man on the planet and
everybody shows up and the two brothers
Tom Hardy and what's the other guy's
name he's a great actor whatever that
guy's name is on that picture Edgerton
freaking sick actor I love Tom is one of
my favorite actors but him and the other
guy Nick Nolte is an alcoholic in a
movie and he trains one of the brothers
and these two guys from two different
brackets end up making it to the
championship and then all of a sudden
the guy announces and says oh you will
not believe the story being built up
behind this these guys are brothers and
they're having one goes into the
military big mess falling out and it
leads into the biggest spectacle
pay-per-view obviously it's a movie okay
so Jake and Logan
if they're trying to make the real-life
Warrior movie to say we're gonna sell
record-breaking pay-per-view bigger than
Conor McGregor and Mayweather and each
of us are going to pick up 100 million
dollars guess what kudos to you if
that's what you're doing and the World's
Gonna Fall forward and they're going to
watch it and will it be entertaining
sure these guys are professional
professional marketers for the last five
years they've each made hip-hop videos
reacting to the other person and saying
you just want to be me and you just want
to be that and they've ran with this now
say that's not the case Okay say it's
real let's just say it's not the case
and it's real a few months ago I made a
video I think they had a following out
with George Janko and then it wasn't a
following out and then Mike reached out
and him and I talked was it a following
not a follow no it's just not a
follow-on okay great I don't know what's
going on over there and uh whether there
was a file or not or not and uh you know
they have a great podcast I think Mike's
a great communicator I think Logan's a
great marketer and I think George was a
good addition to the group obviously the
main draw there is Logan before Logan
you and I probably didn't know Mike or
we didn't know George or Logan kind of
pulled it up and he's done a great job
for himself building a brand creating a
lot of money for a lot of people no
problem
however
if this is a pup if this is real and
they're going through this there's a few
things that I understand it's a modern
day and I said take 90 days off I don't
know if you remember this whole 90 days
Logan Paul take the 90 days off stuff he
reacted to it yeah and he reacted to
making fun of it all these things
so one if it's fake they're full enough
people to make the money go for it if
it's real rule of thumb never publicly
humiliate your family for dollar Keeping
Up with the Kardashians they did it yeah
they're great marketers whatever you
want to put it up they're great they did
this they did that no problem the family
loses a bit of sincerity the family
loses a bit of authenticity It all
becomes an act to get the eyeballs etc
etc if these guys were my sons which
they're not but if they were my sons I
would have a conversation with them and
I would say we have some basic
guidelines guy for this Paul family you
guys can publicly never talk to each
other the way you guys have privately
fight as much as you want publicly you
cannot do this this is not an example
this is why Tate brothers when you see
the videos on how it shows how Tristan
defends Andrew and that goes viral and
it's teaching Brothers to be United and
Logan and Jake showing Logan not being
happy for Jake and them having animosity
that creates dissension and division one
unites a family one divides a family so
if it's an Act take your couple hundred
million dollars is it really worth it I
don't think so I think both of you guys
guys can find ways to make billions and
better ways instead of wanting to beat
you know counters fight or all that
stuff and I understand they're both
competitive I really like Jake really
I'm a big I really like Jake Jake to me
is a very very attractive
um
personality where he's getting wiser and
wiser there's a part of him that I
relate to like if we were in the Army I
probably would have hung out more with
Jake than I would have had with Logan if
we were both 18 100 but I also think
Logan's got an upside to be a president
one day I don't think this is good luck
on what they're doing even if it's a
publicity stunt so anyways we don't know
what's going to happen all I know is
that was my thoughts if you guys got
anything added and then we'll wrap it up
anything they're nothing okay let's
finish up the podcast
um gang
today's what Rob today is today's
Tuesday oh today's Tuesday I thought
it's Thursday today is Tuesday so we got
podcasts on Thursday Thursday three
o'clock we're going to be doing Special
times afternoon cap of the presidential
debate oh Thursday three o'clock we're
reacting to what's going on with uh the
presidential debate yesterday khabib's
interview went out I don't know if you
got sorrow now with the whole thing
about in America we have 100 plus
genders how many do you have in Russia
he gives reaction which has gone taken
off everywhere but also the 54 minutes
of the Tate interview that was not
released we finally got approval I think
that's going out tomorrow
podcast stay tuned it's gonna be ABS
he's gonna tell a story of what they did
when they were spying on him and his
brother in jail you're gonna crack up
when you hear that story having said
that take care everybody bye bye-bye